this is a production of Cornell
University John so about a year and a
half ago I got a call from a colleague
at Michigan State
he said I'm writing a book on
sustainable fruit production and I want
you to write a chapter on sustainable
strawberry production and I saw I have
to get back to you on that and the
reason I want to think about that is
because although I think a lot of the
strawberry production like in this area
is relatively sustainable 95 percent of
the strawberry production in this
country occurs in Florida in California
or I don't think practices are very
sustainable but I didn't want to speak
for behalf of them so I contacted a
colleague who used to work for Driscoll
the research director recently retired I
said Tom I said would you be willing to
co-author a book chapter with me on
sustainable strawberry production you go
strawberries aren't grown sustainably
and so we wrote this chapter on how
strawberries became unsustainable and so
I think it's a pretty good story and so
I want to share that with you today and
I want to give you the story and then I
want to talk about what we're doing
about it
some of our research approaches were
taking try to borrow the best of what
they do in California Florida bring it
here
so my premise is that a major threat to
sustain our food supply is a small
amount of genetic diversity in some of
the crops that we grow and then the fact
we grow in a very you know limited
geographic area so that increases a risk
there's something that happens it's
going to wipe out a significant portion
of the acreage because it's so
concentrated and because the genetic
base is narrow it also leads to
increased risk too and some examples of
that we can take go banana is almost all
bananas with a variety Cavendish the
yellow one you see in a store most of
all you'll see some other varieties with
this mostly Cavendish same thing with
avocado kiwi fruit potato 70% of
potatoes arrested Burbank even there was
a thousand varieties out there 70% are
just one variety and 90% of all
strawberries growing in the u.s. come
from California was just a very limited
number of variety
in California 95% of the production is
annual another was a call of a and
replant every year it's not perennial
like strawberries around here they
produced three billion pounds a year
those average retail price is $2 a pound
so the industry is worth six billion
dollars a year and the yields in
California about six thousand pounds per
acre compared to like here in most other
states around eleven or twelve thousand
pounds per acre so they're really you
know doing a lot of production out there
both in terms of acreage yields and in
terms of total amount of acreage
produced and this is a big deal in
supermarket sales you know almost 20
percent of produce sales in the
supermarket attributed to berries this
is a fruit but you know that far
outpaces citrus and apples and other
things I think that surprises a lot of
people cousin berries were small we got
to account for a big share of the retail
dollar so strawberries once were among
the most sustainably grown crops in the
world and I say this because they were
grown in almost every country and I
think you could argue that strawberries
are the most widely grown fruit crop in
the world when you look at the number of
countries and locations of grow
strawberries are like really all over
the world lots of varieties are used low
inputs required to perennial it's all
those things speak to sort of the
sustainability of strawberry production
and today you can go while Hedrick small
fruits in new york which is published in
1925 he says at the moment the station
up here Geneva has 130 for the varieties
most commonly cultivated in North
America so that suggests that there were
lots of varieties grown and that's kind
of a good thing because you don't have
just a couple of varieties that the
induced suits based on anybody want to
guess is what was the biggest strawberry
growing state a hundred years ago New
York is about tenth no Tennessee and I
see here that here's the ranking from
the most to the least kind of surprising
and you could argue that even today
strawberries are sustainably grown in
lots of places
the world in the deal each I travel
around the world I see you know
strawberries everywhere I go Africa
China Myanmar Netherlands Japan so forth
so but most of the production is very
very concentrated in just a few places
around the world so things have changed
in the last hundred years from this
widely dispersed production hundreds of
just a few places where they grow most
of the strawberries so what's changed
well this we have to go back in history
to kind of give you a sense of what's
going on with the strawberry so the
Europeans were familiar with a couple of
species of strawberry and these species
were diploid yet two sets of chromosomes
they produce very small fruit and so
this is a photograph of what European
strawberry would look like see the
fruits about the size of your little
fingernail and that's what they were
they thought strawberries were and these
diploid strawberries were found
throughout the North temperate regions
of the world so the Europeans are
familiar with them agents they were
growing over here as well but something
interesting happened about a million
years ago is that there was a series of
polyploidy events that happened and
North America ended up with two species
of octopus strawberry a West Coast
pieces and the East Coast species with
eight sets of chromosomes and
proportionally the fruit was like a lot
bigger than the diploid because there
are all these chromosomes and in fruit
crops oftentimes we have higher levels
of fruit size increases so the Europeans
came over they encountered these octopus
strawberries there was so much bigger
than what they were used to and just
last month in Nature Genetics they've
kind of figured out the pattern of how
these octopus came to be we didn't know
that before because it's complex genome
like an octuple is hard to sequence but
they finally knot it and figured it out
and the paper is published in Nature
Genetics but what they know is that
there are a couple of diploid species in
Japan that hybridized on a polyp
polyploidy you ended up with a
tetraploid that type deployed then
crossed with a diploid over here to give
us a hexaploid and it's somewhere around
the bering sea or maybe
we're here in Alaska this hexaploid
crossed with the diploid from North
America come up with the Aqua plates and
then those spread down the coast all the
way down into South America so if you
remember the picture I showed you of the
diploid strawberry the wild strawberry
this is the optically wild strawberry
and we're going to have this around here
this is called fer Guerra virginiana
it's octopus and the Europeans of course
didn't know about this plant until they
came over here and Jacques Cartier of
France found these strawberries these
big octopus strawberries and took them
back with France all excited about them
because they were so big and he named
them Bagheri virginiana claiming them in
the gardens and there they grew for a
long time this is a strawberry on the
west coast for Gary and chiloensis it's
also occupied the Europeans didn't
discover it until later because to get
to the west coast you had to go all the
way down around South America and back
up the other side and the Mapuche
Indians had been selecting for Garriga
chiloensis for a while and he got bigger
fruit and some of it was actually kind
of white in color it was a little bit
bigger and so when the Europeans were
down there they were impressed with the
size of the strawberry in fact one of
the first people that was sent to Chile
was this guy Emma de Frise Fraser who
was a French lieutenant in the army but
he was sent to Chile to spy on the
Spanish because a Spanish thing kind of
confident so in French ah you know what
was up they sent this guy down there
like spy he's also supposed to take
notes on what was going on and send it
back to king louis xiv but his last name
was actually strawberry it's like
lieutenant strawberry so he was all
excited when he found these really big
strawberries and he knew king louis xiv
had gardens so he sent these strawberry
plants back to the king said king you
won't believe how big this strawberry
fruit is you plant those out they're
gonna be amazing next year so he sent
him over in a boat you get the France
they planted him out and they flowered
but nothing happened and that's sure
they flowered and nothing happened
but Frasier didn't know and colleagues
didn't know the time we realized is that
this species is dioecious and we dig out
plants with fruit and send it halfway
around the world
there's no male pollen to pollinate the
strawberry soda flower but it won't set
fruit so quite a while later this
mystery berry started showing up and
nobody really knew what it was and in
nineteen in the 1700s and it was a
really big fruit I mean really big not
just like octopus size but even bigger
than that and it was took Duchesne some
of you remember that name from taxonomy
he figured out oh this is a hybrid
between forget virginiana the cartier
brought back and forget chiloensis it
was brought back by lieutenant
strawberry and they crossed and so not
only did you have the octopi nature but
you had hybrid vigor in a result in a
really big strawberry and that was the
basis of our cultivated strawberry
that's how it came to be so a lot of the
breeding was happening in Europe and
then those rise were sent back to the
Americas where they were planted so for
the next 200 years
growers both in this country and Europe
around the world grew these vergara and
an aster strawberries and a NASA if you
know and ass is the genus of pineapple
and so the flavor of some of these early
strawberries reminded people of
pineapple so they call it the basically
the for Garry up pineapple sharing Anna
NASA that's how it got the name and
forget it comes to the root word
fragrance so the pineapple fragrances
how strawberry was named anyway these
berries were grown in Europe and America
there were short day plants they form
flower buds into the short days of fall
they went through the winter and then in
the spring the long days of the summer
really make runners and then in the fall
that you make flowers again so they've
rooted one time of year that a big peak
of production run around June and then
that was it because after June the days
are long they're not making flowers
anymore so give this big peak of
production and okay right there you're -
and you're
three in year four and you can keep
these as perennials they were food every
year in the springtime based on daily
insensitivity and these strawberries are
still going today you still find a lot
of June bearing strawberries being grown
oh this is one you can still were
different catalogs it was released in
1942 it's called Sparkle and again you
can see it's a little bit bigger than
those wild strawberries but it's still
not as big as the ones you get in the
supermarket the big breakthrough sort of
led to this big change in strawberry
production was made by my academic
grandfather Roy spring Hurst who is a
strawberry breeder in California or for
UC Davis and he remembered growing up in
a was--that's mountains of Utah and he
said you know I was up in the mountains
in the summertime I picked strawberries
and the only way those strawberries
would produce fruit is they have to be
long day plants or they're not sensitive
alias or something because when the days
are short it's too cold up there for
anything to grow so they must be
completing their lifecycle when the days
are relatively long so he went up to
Utah got those plants brought him back
down and sure enough they didn't respond
like a regular strawberry plant they
didn't respond to short days they
flowered as long as it wasn't too hot or
too cold so he said you know what I'm
gonna cross those with a commercial
strawberry variety I'm gonna come up
with a plant with big fruit it's gonna
flower over a long period of time and
not just one time and he did and boy it
really took the industry by storm so now
you could plant these strawberries and
get fruit the first year and then you
could hold them over for a second year
and get a peak in June so that was real
exciting and there were two when I
started my career there were two giants
in the strawberry breeding world
it was Royce bring her so I mentioned in
jingle Atta who worked for the USDA in
Beltsville Maryland and they both said
we're gonna take these strawberries
these gnudi nutri strawberries we're
gonna really make something of it and
jingle lettuce said you know we're gonna
breed these strawberries for good flavor
we're gonna bring for disease resistance
we're not gonna have to fumigate the
soil they're going to be resistant to
insects
past they're gonna be the best thing to
come along and that's how we're gonna go
which bring her said with that that's
that's too many genes to work with
there's too much to mess around I'm only
gonna breathe for flavor I'm not I'm not
grief remembering for size and
productivity and we're gonna fumigate
we're not gonna breathe for diseases so
we're gonna fumigate
that's not gonna take care of our
disease problems and so they both sort
of went at it in sort of two divergent
directions and the eastern strategy
emphasis on flavor eating quality so
disease resistance and the fumigation or
plastic mulch California on the other
hand size and yield shipping quality
they use both short day and danger two
varieties they fumigated a lot of
plastic and they used the new type of
plant propagule instead of planting
strawberries when they're dormant they
planted strawberries when they were
alive and growing in the field in
October and I'll show you how you do
that in a second they dig them out of
the ground bare root and take him to the
production fields and planted them so
what California figured out they could
do was they would take strawberry plants
that they wanted to produce and they
would grow them in hot conditions under
long days and then we make runners
Austin runners then they would dig those
plants so these are the the little
elevation nurseries in the Central
Valley they're what's really hot they
would dig those plants with all those
runners they move them up north into the
high elevation nurseries where it was
cooler and when the days got shorter in
October they would dig those plants up
again and Transplant them down here for
the production fuels along the coast
where it was nice and mild in the winter
not too hot not too cold
so by moving these plants like to three
different locations they were able to
produce strawberries over a long period
of time so in the end of the 70s this is
what the production peak look like in
California just the big peak just like
we have except ours is in June a little
bit later but they were able to knock
that curve down quite a bit in 20 years
before the production was a little bit
more even throughout the months of the
year and so supermarkets like that
because they could go to these producers
and the producers could get
to them strawberries over much longer
period of time Florida was doing the
same thing except they were growing
their strawberries in Nova Scotia where
it was cold and cool short days and
digging them in October and planting
them down in Florida they're using the
same thing the bare root plants like
right on the ground and stuck in the
plastic now because these varieties that
were adapted to the system were not
selected through disease resistance
grows had a fumigate really had a
fumigate because they were growing these
as annuals every year back in the same
site so you had a fumigate to clean the
soil a pathogens before you could plant
again and so they were fumigating every
year and then the Montreal Protocol was
signed in 1997 it said we're going to
phase-out methyl bromide because it's
depleting the ozone layer and the only
uses are going to be critical exemptions
where you have no other choice but you
have to use it so an example of a
critical exemption might be imported
fruit from a country that might have a
fruit fly and so you could fumigate a
container to kill the maggot or whatever
but strawberry growers because they were
so politically connected got 12
consecutive years of exemption and they
continued to fumigate with methyl
bromide for 12 years after it was
supposed to be phased out the other
thing that growers do is they make these
plastic beds every year and they plant
the strawberries every run this plastic
and there's a lot of plastic used to
grow strawberries in fact I did a
calculation to figure out how much is
used but I found out there is enough
used to circle the world 12 times every
year for the 4-foot with the plastic and
then these plants that are dug out
bare-root they're not dormant crowns
they're just like take a plant on the
ground and plant it as plastic in
October in Florida is still pretty warm
there in California they might do it a
little bit earlier so pretty once you
got these plants it is just starting to
wilt so I know I'm plastic so you got to
irrigate them and not just drip
irrigation you got to put overhead
irrigation on them to keep them from
completely collapsing so for
two weeks they overhead irrigate their
strawberry fields for two weeks in less
water they put on these fields in a two
week period five hundred thousand
gallons per acre the first two weeks
they got these plants established and if
you go to California this is a famous
sort of a photograph here the San
Joaquin Valley you know this is where
the ground was in 1925 this is where it
is in 1977 its subsiding because the
ground water is being pumped out and you
know but you gotta have your strawberry
plants established so that's what you
got to do it right and then pest
management another thing in Florida
we're just a little bit humid and hot
there but strawberry growers they spray
every week every week they spray it on a
weekly spray schedule for 22 weeks in a
row that's what they did if you buy
strawberries today from the supermarket
I went a couple days ago and bought here
from Florida
they've been sprayed 22 times and for
the most part now one of my colleagues
Natalie Perez is working down there to
try to reduce fungicide use in
strawberries and she's gotten about half
a strawberry growers to adopt this
advisory system it's like an IPM system
with weather stations all it tells you
when to apply your pesticide with based
on the weather and not just because it's
Monday and she has been able to get
about half the growers to reduce their
fungicide by 30 to 50 percent so it's
significant but it's still a lot of
fungicide still out of fungicide and
then last week it comes out the Dirty
Dozen that strawberries have all this
pesticide residue and this is in
Friday's USA Today right in front of the
money section the Dirty Dozen now I
don't want to give this any credibility
because there's so many problems with it
but the point is that strawberries have
this bad PR about being overly spraying
with pesticide and there's some truth to
it in Florida in some of these
production systems strawberries here are
not sprayed nearly that many times if at
all dependent on the weather but they
get labeled as bad just the same
so California in particular and Florida
have figured out this really intricate
system with just a few specific
cultivars Doug from the production Doug
from the conditioning feels it's just
the right time chilled for just the
right length of time planted at just the
right time and specific field locations
along the coast of California to give
them these high yields and what they've
been able to do now this is last year
this is a production peak over the
season and in here there's not many
strawberries being produced but Florida
is filling in this gap but when
California starts coming in bow now you
know look how constant that production
peak is a combination of these short day
and do you know two varieties and all
these manipulations are doing with this
real fine-tuning it's pretty impressive
pretty impressive and so if you look at
their acreage the green bar is it's
really shot up particularly last 30
years and yield per acre again it's just
really shot up over the last three years
so they figured out how to do it really
precisely in really well so you've never
been to California to see that
production fields here's a few examples
and people around the world have been
impressed with this production system so
let's take it somewhere else where we
can do it this is really great so
where's this right it's a little white
spot there from the satellite the let's
zoom down in there these are all
strawberry Turtles they say the great
balls are made man-made structure you
can see from space you cannot see the
great well from space but you can see
strawberry production fills in southern
Spain so they've taken a California
system and they put plastic over the top
of it to mediate against weather
extremes and so forth and so they're
kind of doing the same thing but in
another part of the world they're
getting really concentrated at one
little area where the climates just
right so here we are in our area
northern strawberries you got these
lower yields we have this perennial
system we harvest for four or five weeks
then we're kind of done and this is what
our system looks like it's not bad but
you know the yields aren't nearly as
high and the seasons not as long so a
question is what's more sustainable what
they're doing in California Florida or
what we're doing here and if you go down
almost every category it seems like the
perennial system is more sustainable
than the annual system almost every
category you look at but this is just
sort of you know qualitative it's not
very quantitative so I did some work and
did some literature review for this
chapter that I was writing on lifecycle
analysis and people have done this for
strawberries and grown in various parts
of the world and they look at the amount
of co2 produced per unit kilogram of
crop so in California strawberry
production they emit 1.75 kilogram of
co2 per kilogram of fruit produced in
North Carolina where they grow a lot of
strawberries numbers much higher that's
because the yields are lower so the co2
per kilogram produced would be even
higher in North Carolina but we'll pay
California I found in our paper that
looked at in the nursery operations at
6% more co2 packaging more co2 and in
transportation I calculated how much
diesel fuel tractor-trailer uses by
shipping a truckload of berries from
Watsonville to New York City to the
terminal market and figured out all out
and come up with another increment of
co2 and I figured out if you convert the
co2 that's produced by glucose that's
inside a strawberry to the mouse glucose
you have to burn to get the equivalent
amount of co2
it's 22 to one so in other words to make
the same amount of co2 you have to burn
22 kilograms of glucose that gives you
the same amount of co2 that you produced
one kilogram of strawberry with its
energy equivalent
so I don't if you think that's good or
you think that's bad 22:01 doesn't sound
real good to me but the other thing I
got to thinking about was you know most
of that carbon dioxide is generated
through burning diesel fuel it's not
generated by burning sugar I mean it's
one unit you can use to make comparisons
among crops but what if we calculate how
much energy is used if we looked at it
in terms of diesel fuel because diesel
fuel is more efficient at converting
energy okay burning and making energy
without releasing a lot of co2 so if we
do it with diesel fuel total co2
generated per kilogram of strawberry
same number three point two eight one
litre diesel fuel produces this much co2
we divide this into this we got one
point two litres of diesel fuel for
every kilogram of strawberry produced
each kilogram of diesel fuel contains 11
million calories if we divide that by
the calories in a kilogram of strawberry
the ratio comes out to almost 20
thousand the one so if 22 is like wow
that might be except with twenty
thousand one probably isn't so the point
is there's a huge amount of energy that
goes into growing strawberries where
they're grown now the shipping across
the country to us driven by consumer
demand an expectation that will have
strawberries every week of the year in
the supermarket so let's go through the
checklist balance is still on
sustainability checklist little crop
rotation check immigration check hi
plastic use check excessive energy use
check mom use pesticide use dependency
an undocumented workers
you know half the workers in California
are undocumented so I don't think that's
real sustainable either if you base your
industry on this supply of undocumented
workers particularly and this a
political climate
product growing far from consumer its
check flavor is inconsistent I would
also argue that we don't want to create
a food system where the food doesn't
taste good if you want to fish this way
food taste good or you want to buy it
and I don't know the story
last week there pretty rough in terms of
flavor and very inconsistent and so
there's this tendency for growers to
choose varieties that will be large and
produce a lot of fruit without regard to
flavor and this argument about flavor
and strawberries goes way back this is a
variety called Wilson's Albany was
released in 1853 the acreage after this
variety was released in North America
went from 1500 150,000 and most of it
was just right here Wilson's Albany
because it produced really high yields a
big fruit but probably didn't taste too
good because there was this someone may
recognize this name Henry Ward Beecher
he was a famous theologian at the time
but he wrote a lot of editorials
in papers and he said this fiction is
berry is enough to turn a horror of
cultures heart against this kind is a
wickedest barrier that's ever indulged
with liberty it's an invention by which
producers make money online consumers
misery has every quality of excellence
except in the matter of eating so what
we're trying to do with our research is
take some practices that kind of work in
California and maybe bring them here so
even though some of those practices
might not be truly a really sustainable
at least it might be better than what
we're doing now so we're gonna look at
some of the practices they do there and
see which ones might work here it's what
we're trying to do and so the first
thing we're gonna do is like borrow
their varieties because they've done a
pretty good job bringing some of these
nice big varieties of people are used to
purchasing and this one in particular
albian if you pick it when it's right
it's pretty good so we've screened a
number of varieties over the years and
we think albion is just the right one to
go with because it has flavor and if
we're going to compete with California
in a Dean neutral season which is not
June so of July August September we got
to have something to taste better than
what you can get at the store so let's
go with the best flavored strawberry so
we're going with albion i'm not going to
show you data on yields and so field
trials and so forth
but these are some production fields and
one of the things about growing these
strawberries in the summer and into the
fall up here is that if we can get fog
and get read as you all know the weather
is not so great so if you put these the
neutral strawberries from California on
under tunnels oh my they really respond
to that they love it and they just grow
beautifully and it keep on growing the
thing is they don't stop in October they
stop early November and so we can now
grow strawberries from late May early
June all the way through to early
November locally right here which is
kind of exciting going from like five
weeks to five months of strawberry
production but we have to do these
tunnels to make it work so that's the
downside but what's worse using a tunnel
that we can plastic that we can reuse
for like three years or shipping those
strawberries 3,000 miles the other thing
when we use these tunnels disease just
pretty much goes away powdery mildew but
try to some of these major diseases of
strawberries it just doesn't happen
under these tunnels so these are some of
our tunnels is what it looks like we
have these metal hoops with plastic over
then we have these bungee cords that
help hold the plastic down we raise one
side of it so that air movement and that
bees in and and so forth and that the
humidity evaporate and then if it's
gonna rain or get coal we just pull the
side down so that events over then we
can raise it again I'm not the
strawberries do two thing
November 10th look at that that's not
bad
so because these are entirely new thing
we have to kind of start the beginning
and figure like everything out about
growing these things like what Col have
already is when do we play it we've done
Studies on planting dates both here in a
Geneva with corny Weber my colleague and
you can see one of our experiments here
with different size plants because these
are planted at different times and we
look at the yield and every time you
know we know that around if you wait
till after midnight the plants they'll
do very well
you'll falls off dramatically the longer
you wait to plant them same thing it's
true here in Ithaca so you learned that
we were curious about fertigation how do
we fertilize these things we first
started introducing the growers the
plants didn't do very well because
growers are fertilizing the day-neutral
strawberries just like they were the do
barren strawberries which is fertilize
them a couple times a year maybe three
times a year these they have to be
spoon-fed
they have to have fertilizer every week
about but we did studies to figure out
what the optimal rate was it looks
around somewhere around five pounds of
actual nitrogen per acre a week gives us
the best yield we've done this over a
couple of years and in the second year
if you hold them into the second year
you know it doesn't make a big
difference but you know giving that five
pounds every week seems to be the
difference between having them perform
well and not this is a interesting
experiments an overwintering trial so we
know these plants will overwinter and
fruit the following spring so you're not
just getting fruit that first year you
plant but you can hold them over pick a
crop in the spring of the second year
but growers have reported really
variable success in overwintering
strawberries so we were trying to figure
out why do sometimes they overwinter
well and sometimes they don't so he set
up an experiment that was designed to
vary the carbohydrate status of the
strawberry plant going into winter so we
did some things that we thought would
increase the carbohydrate status of the
plant going into winter and how we did
that was we
the flowers off in the fall so they
didn't get that in November crop we
pinched flowers off on October 1st from
there on and I'll cover 15th from there
on so the plants would have a chance to
build up carbohydrate before winter and
they're nothing we did instead of using
straw mulch which is your standard cover
we used a floating row cover for winter
protection and that allows light to
penetrate so again we thought well maybe
some of that light will help those
plants build up some carbohydrates and
overwinter better and then we did some
things deliberately to reduce the
carbohydrate status of the plant one was
to mulch early put that straw on in
minimum November well there's still warm
days and light out there so the plants
are under the dark for quite a long
period of time so we had an early
mulching with straw and another thing we
did was we took these plants that we
sprayed them every week with a foliar
application of urea and when you do that
to plants it requires carbon structures
to assimilate the urea and nitrogen so
that drives down the carbohydrates to be
fertilized so we had three treatments of
increased carbohydrate stats and three
dudes least in theory decreased and so
here the plants coming out of winter
they look a little tough but some plots
you know the plants are still green the
leaves are still there the rate of Grove
and other plots kind of like mostly dead
so the treatments really didn't make a
difference and here's what we saw plants
alive in the fall you know you don't
expect any differences because we
haven't done any real treatments yet so
that all mostly alive going into the
fall and coming out spring the other end
some real differences here
the treatments with two sheets a row
cover where they had light did pretty
well five and six where we removed
flowers they did really well but I
wanted it terrible was when we applied
foliar fertilizer every week driving
down the carbohydrate levels the plants
didn't survive very well through the
winter and if you look at yields at the
end of those plants per plant yield the
following spring kind of see the same
patterns we see the two treatments where
we removed flowers early to give them
developing carbohydrates not only went
through the winter better but came out
the other end with higher yielding plans
so we think we know what's going on
we're gonna look at actual carbohydrate
levels in your bill is going to help us
do that so we can quantify how much
starch is being used up toy to winter
under these various treatments and then
lastly we did an insect's exclusion
trial we were there's these insects that
bother strawberries and we were
wondering how could we exclude them with
netting and how big would their any have
to be before we compromise pollination
so he took four different sized nets and
these different colors of the different
size and any we could get and we grew
the strawberries under him with the nets
down all season long and you can see
again the plots close-up of some of the
net in we harvested the fruit and what
we found was really interesting like I
expected that when we started to get
fine net that he also start to drop
because we weren't going to get
pollination or wind movement but we
didn't we got the opposite but tighter
than any was the higher the yields were
so these fruits these flowers being
pollinated even without B activity
they're being pollinated he's really
tight mosquito net names and so forth
and when I shared this data and I'm
meeting in Washington State
in October the Mexico strawberry girl
said oh this is a shading effect the
closer you're putting the finer than
that the more shade you get and the
day-neutral plants like that shade and
last year we had a really hot summer and
so they said this is shading it's making
a difference and they really don't need
pollination like we typically think they
do so this year we're going to test that
out we've got working with a company
that's gonna provide us with this shade
cloth but it also has holes in it to
exclude insects but these reflective
strips can come at different densities
so we're going to get three different
densities we're gonna put it over the
strawberry row at three different
densities we're going to put
the plastic top on to keep the rain out
we're not going to lower it unless we
have to but then we're going to see
whether we get a shaving effect so
hypotheses be the more of these we have
the more light that we reflect back the
cooler the plants will be and maybe our
yields will go up in response to that
who knows who knows or Java T Pauling
falling down yeah maybe wind yeah so
we're working with some other colleagues
around the country we have colleagues at
Michigan State University New Hampshire
Penn State and we put together a
strawberry production guide we're
updating periodically this is on the web
you can download it has all the latest
information that we've all gathered from
our various institutions put it in one
place so we can extend this to growers
so in conclusion I think the technology
and techniques from California the
Florida can be used to grow strawberries
in other regions closer to consumers
resulting in an overall lower
environmental impact
I think tunnels offer tremendous
advantages to growers and extreme
climates and as the climate keeps
changing at more extremes more heavy
rainfall patterns all the tunnels can
help mediate that and I think provide
growers has some advantages and then
lastly I think we're still using plastic
both as mulch as covers we have to have
a long way to go before I think we can
say that we truly have strawberries as a
sustainable crop in New York or anywhere
else in the world so thank you
[Applause]
but then you chose once cultivar from
California to plant here should we have
right we should and so if we had lots of
cultivars that taste good then I would
say yes right now we have one column
rather taste good that's Albion and so
my friend and colleague Courtney Webber
is gonna come up with a whole bunch of
Dana the strawberries that taste really
good they're gonna be adapted here but
you're absolutely right it's against not
sustainable we're basing on albion but
really if you try these it's the only
one that you would say tastes better
than what you can get in the store it's
nice what we're going with right now
sore still right at the infancy I think
of this whole new way of growing
strawberries that was those are growing
on benches and so I was sort of down
under looking up under the fact it was
like a interestly enough yes so if
Driscoll's is moving wholesale towards
some of these wreaths bad cultures on
benches and the reason is not what you
might think it's so they can get a robot
in there to harvest of fruit so they're
no they've got these robots now that
they're working on that can strawberries
a difficult thing to harvest
mechanically that's why they're still
harvested by hand the reason is the
first fruit ripens and then a couple
days later two more ripen and a couple
days later for more ripen on the
inflorescence and it happens over a
period of several weeks so a picker
robotic picker has to go in just choose
the red fruit and it doesn't have an
incision layer like a blueberry or a
raspberry so you have to actually pull
it cut it and then put it in the
container and so that's really hard for
a robot to do because the canned dam is
the other fruit house going in there the
slicer has to work
you have to not squeeze it too hard but
because of the labor situation justice
that we've got to put our eggs in a
basket of figuring out how to harvest
these things without labor and the best
way to do it is to grow them up so that
a robot can straddle and harvest as it
goes down so right now they're testing
brownie but coconut core is one that
seems to work the best and they're our
first early trials they're just starting
on this it's starting yeah it's pretty
interesting yeah you said that
Driscoll's does contract for some
organic strawberry production given all
of the fumigation that hers there how
are those organic berries being grown
yeah so in that case there with the
organics they can't fumigate so they're
they're trading with other growers like
vegetable growers like this guy is
growing lettuce so why don't we switch
fields for a couple of years and I can
grow my strawberries in your lettuce
film and doing that and the price
differential between conventional
organic strawberries is narrow it's
almost nothing now it's really and
there's a big supply of strawberries in
the market right now in fact this last
year was the first year that California
acreage actually went down for the first
time in decades
overall acreage overall acreage went
down well I think it's all these things
coming into play yeah and it's shipped
into Mexico yeah so the Beltsville
strawberry program is still going strong
they're still looking at the neutral
strawberries are looking at tunnels and
so forth but it's not because of funding
it's not nearly as big and robust as it
once was but it's still there it's still
there it's still releasing varieties
there's this not a lot of collected our
first reading interest yeah none of
those not not at this point no the
question great question snap these
farmers are using methyl bromide why are
they using while they're using methyl
iodide so they wait long and I was like
is twits the valence of the compound
there and still use something very
similar but that's kind of expensive so
they're also using chloropicrin you're
using vape and they're just using other
fumigants they haven't gotten away from
fumigation they just switched to other
two minutes that are more expensive but
the problem that they're having is that
the California pesticide regulators keep
increasing the buffer zone around the
fields when you fumigate so if you had
like 10 acres at one point the goose now
you're down to like just the middle
square because you have to have all this
buffer around the outside edge so
they're getting kind of squeezed out of
that acreage because of that research
reading yeah so Jonathan's pointing out
that strawberries seem to be very you
know specific in their response to
different things and undoubtedly you
know new varieties to come out it might
be they need different fertilizer rates
and and different your planting dates
and so forth that's absolutely true
but we got to start somewhere so I
thought that's all I can say that Geneva
do you have any questions so you you hit
on the lifecycle with the co2 can you
take some of your current cultural
practices and now go back to that model
and see how the New York system fits
into them I know if you take out the
transport
datian part you're taking out a lot
right there but if you can look looking
at some of the other factors Oh how
we're doing in that regard yeah so I'd
be a really good question is something
I'd really like to do sometimes we do
lifecycle analysis of our own production
system I don't have that expertise if I
had somebody with the expertise to do
that I'd love to partner with them and
figure out what it is for us because we
lose the transportation but we also have
other expenses too like the plastic
covering that they don't necessarily use
in California and our yields are lower
so that influences the ratio as well
that's a great suggestion I'd love to be
able to do that with so much okay thank
you very much this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu